صمود اوكرانيا في حرب هذا روسيا مشاهدينا
لم يكن طبعا لولا تدفق الاسلحه الغربيه
كميات ضخمه من الاسلحه ارسلت الى الجيش
الاوكراني الذي وقف ندا للند امام القوات
الروسيه في اكثر من جبهات لكن هل تستفيد
اوكرانيا بشكل كلي من الاسلحه الغربيه
سؤال طرحته صحيفه من خلال تقرير يشير الى
مخاوف من ان نسبه من الاسلحه المقدمه الى
اوكرانيا تهرب الى السوق السوداء اذا
اردنا ان ندخل في التفاصيل تشير الصحيفه
الى انكياف بصدد خوض حرب اخرى موازيه
لكنها داخليه هذه المره في مواجهه الفساد
فتهريب الاسلحه يعد ظاهره منتشره في
اوكرانيا حتى قبل اندلاع الحرب مع روسيا
ما جعل هذا الموضوع يطفو الى السطح هو
تداول تقارير عن بيع صواريخ وطائرات
الجافلين وسويتش بليد عبر الانترنت قادمه
من اوكرانيا كما ان مسؤولين امريكيين
اشاروا الى تسجيل حالات مشتبه فيها لعمليه
تهريب اسلحه الا كثر من ذلك هو تقديم
مراقبي البانتاجون لحوالي 200 شكوى تزعم
رصد سوء استخدام الاسلحه في اوكرانيا
شبهه تهريب الاسلحه دفعت واشنطن الى اصدار
اوامر بتتبع ومراقبه الاسلحه المقدمه
لاوكرانيا لضمان استخدامها على النحو
المطلوب وتبقى مهمه مراقبه الاسلحه الصعبه
نوعا ما قياسا للكميه الكبيره التي تم
تسليمها لحد الان وهو معترفت به الكساندرا
استينوفا رئيسه لجنه مراقبه الاسلحه في
البرلمان الاوكراني والتي قالت انه من
المستحيل لمراجعه مخزون الاسلحه بشكل
مستمر لكنها وفي الوقت نفسه نفت وجود اي
دليل على عمليات نقل اسلحه غير مشروعه
الجيش الاوكراني حقيقه يدرك جيدا خطوره
عمليه تهريب الاسلحه ليس فقط لانها تستنفذ
مخزوناته بل ايضا لانها قد تؤثر على تدفق
الاسلحه نفسها حيث ان واشنطن المحت الى
امكانيه تقليص امداداتها في حال ثبوت وجود
عمليات تهريب ضخمه وهو ما دفع بعض الجنود
الاوكران الى مخاطره بحياتهم للحفاظ على
الاسلحه من السوق السوداء تقول صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز كما تضيف ان بعض الجنود
اضطروا الى العوده لساحات المعركه والتاكد
من خلوها من اي اسلحه وذلك خشيه ان يحصل
عليها الجنود الروس او اي طرف اخر وهو ما
وضع كثيرين منهم في خطر حقيقي لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات